if you
Jesus is Holy and he alone is worthy
of our praise.
It's a beautiful morning, it's so good to be
gathered together with the body of Christ. Amen.
Well today the message I have for us.
Is a timely message.
For you for me for us as
a church.
Because some of you walked in here this morning.
feeling low
and isolated
and wondering if you matter at
all.
Hang with me because God's word will encourage
you today.
And some of you let's be honest some of you galloped in
here on your high horse.
Hang with me because God's word will humble you
today?
Again, good morning. My name is Ryan Whittaker and
it is a joy to serve as one of your elders here.
I consider being able to share God's word
with you this morning such an incredible honor. So thank
you for this opportunity.
John is away this morning. He is
honoring his former congregation there in
Fort Worth.
For their 75th Anniversary, so pray for John pray
for Normandale Baptist.
And also Brett this morning is preaching at
all of it Baptist and view of his call which we talked about
last week. So pray for them both.
now if you will turn in your Bibles with me to First
Corinthians chapter 12
First Corinthians is in the middle of your new testament. It's
right after acts in Romans.
And while you're turning there, John has been walking us
through a series called Jesus.
to love him is to dot dot dot
And so far we've we've learned how the study
of God's word is the most transformative discipline
we can do.
We learned about prayer and how that deepens our relationship
with Jesus.
And last week we learned about fasting which which
grows us into humility and
dependence and focus on him.
This morning we're looking at serving.
Which that's our main point today, Jesus to love
him is to serve.
in unity drives why we serve
Unity drives why we serve
So, where do we see that?
In the Bible that Unity drives where we why
we serve well, we'll see it like a banner being
unfurled before us as we read First Corinthians now
in this letter Paul is writing to believers.
And Paul is writing into and speaking into
a specific situation.
What is this? What is the situation he's speaking about?
Well, imagine that we're in a plane.
And we're flying over the city
of Corinth.
And it's night time.
And you look out the small circle window down
below.
and you see and you hear
boom
boom boom
explosions
all over the ground below lighting up
the night sky
and that is a good picture of the Corinthian Church.
It's exploding from
but it's not from from bombs or grenades or
gunfire.
But rather from mortar shelves of
division and fighting and
critical spirits.
In the church is being torn apart.
by the shrapnel of snobbery
and one upmanship and in jealousy
in the place is spiritually war-torn and it
is messy.
This is starting to feel real.
This division is the main reason that Paul is
writing First Corinthians.
And we see this in First Corinthians 1:10, very
clearly.
I appeal to you Brothers by the name of our Lord Jesus Christ
that all of you agree.
And that there be no divisions among you but that you be United in
the same mind and the same judgment.
For it's been reported to me by Chloe's people that there
is quarreling among you my brothers.
So Paul saying I appeal to you that that you
agree that there be no divisions among you no
quarreling that you be United.
Paul is saying to the Corinthians into all churches across the
ages. Your church is a mess of
division.
Let's clean this place up.
It's kind of like your mom who says I am going to sit here
and I'm gonna watch you until you do it.
So now let's land the plane in chapter 12
where we find ourselves today.
Let's dig into God's word together our authority over
anything that might come out of my mouth today. This
is our anchoring truth. We say around here.
Now this isn't normal practice for us.
But as one body.
Let's all stand together if you're able for
the reading of God's word.
As I read First Corinthians 12 verse 12 through
27.
For just as the body is one and has many members and all
the members of the body though many are one
body. So it is with Christ.
For in one Spirit. We were all baptized into
the body Jews or Greek slaves are free
and all were made to drink of one spirit.
For the body does not consist of one member but of many.
If the foot should say because I'm not a hand. I do not belong to
the body. That would not make it any less a part of the body.
And if the ear should say because I am not an eye.
I do not belong to the body. That would not make it any less a
part of the body.
If the whole body were an eye where would be the
sense of hearing if the whole body were an ear where would
be the sense of smell?
But as it is God arranged the members in
the body each one of them as he chose
if all were a single member, where would
the body be?
As it is there are many parts. You have one body.
The eye cannot say to the hand. I have no need of you nor
again the head to the feet. I have no need of you.
On the contrary the parts of the body that seem to be weaker or
indispensable and on
the parts of the body that we think less honorable. We bestow the
greater honor.
And our unpresentable parts are treated with greater modesty,
which are more presentable parts. Do not
require.
But God has so composed the body giving greater
honor to the part that lacked it that there
may be no division in their body that the members
may have the same care for one another.
If one member suffers all suffer together, if one
member is honored all Rejoice together. Now, you
are the body of Christ and individually
members of it.
This is the word of the Lord.
You can be seated.
Let's dive in the first point that scripture shows us
is that we serve because we're United We Serve
because we're United.
Remember the context of First Corinthians rampant explosive
division the opposite
of unity.
And in light of this disunity Paul is
trying to show us here in verse 12.
of this truth
for just as one just as the body is one and
has many members and all the members of the body though
many are one body. So it is with Christ.
The truth Paul reminds the Church of is that we
are united as one body.
And he compares the church as a body or to a
body. He's primarily talking about the local church here.
And just like the body is one that has many
members. So the church is one with many
members.
Now when Paul talks of the church as a
body, it's just a metaphor.
It's not some metaphysical claim that the church is literally
Christ's body.
We see throughout scripture that the church is
referred to by many metaphors. We've seen Vine flock.
a building a field
And each metaphor carries with it uniquely beautiful
Church truths about the church.
Now you may ask who belongs to the body of Christ?
Well Paul is excited to tell you.
It's all of us.
every single one of us
if
we are a believer.
that
that condition is implicit and it is
important remember again that Paul is
writing this letter to the Corinthian Church to
believers.
three times Paul tells us this in verse 13
for in one Spirit. We are all that's number
one all baptized into one body Jews or
Greeks slaves or free now this
Limitless diversity means all that's
number two.
In all number three, we're made to
drink of one spirit.
Now this kind of baptism and spirit language maybe
unfamiliar to you. So what does it
mean to be baptized in the spirit into the body into drink
of one spirit?
Well, it's important to understand that Paul's not writing of
the physical act of baptism that we see here on
Sundays.
No water baptism is a symbolic worshipful
profession of your faith in Jesus in obedience
to Jesus command.
The water baptism doesn't save us.
No.
Paul in verse 13 isn't talking about what we do in the baptistry.
But is instead talking about Spirit baptism, which
is part of our salvation.
We see in scripture how the Holy Spirit comes to dwell in
you to take up permanent residence in you.
When you understand yourself as a
sinner you turn away from your sins and you confess Jesus as
Lord.
To make this clear if you are a Believer, then
you are in the body of Christ.
And if you are a Believer you have drunk of the
Holy Spirit.
Conversely if you are not a Believer, then you are
not in the body of Christ.
Romans 8:9 says anyone who does not have the spirit of
Christ does not belong to him.
So let's go back to the text these two verses verses 12 to
13. Paul uses the word one.
five times
so in the face of explosions of division in the church
Paul is saying we are united to the
body of Christ.
So and also that we are to be
United in the body of Christ.
So we should act like it.
Take a moment now and look around this room.
No one in here is your enemy.
If we are one body in
Christ.
picking back up in verse 14
For the body does not consist of one member but of many.
The implication here is that there
are many parts.
Not many I not many identical parts to
be clear. That'd be terrifying. Imagine
a body full of noses.
But that we have many different parts and each part
serves a different purpose in the body.
That's our second point we serve because we are
different.
We serve because we're different.
As it goes we know that the body works best when all the
different parts are are healthy and are working together.
But then what what diseases creep in
to make the body unhealthy?
Well, we see two here.
Let's read about the first starting in verse 15.
If the foot should say because I'm not a hand. I do not belong to the
body. That would not make it any less a part of the body
and if the ear should say because I'm not an eye.
I do not belong to the body. That would not make
it any less a part of the body.
First what's going on here with the foot?
The foot sees the hand is more important.
So it might say something like oh hand lettering
is so beautiful.
Why isn't there such a thing as foot lettering?
Right or the hand looks like it's having so much fun hint a
thumb wrestling, right?
or
the hand is really slapping the base.
He's jamming with his band that looks like
a lot of fun right or the ears struggling to
you and he's comparing itself to the eye. Oh the eye is so
beautiful.
Or the I can control how much light
it lets in.
Why can't I control how loud Things Are?
Or why does the driver's license have eye color,
but not your size.
blue xl
and so therefore the foot and the ear are both feeling low.
Wondering if they really matter at all.
Each or defeat it and they declare I'm not a
part of the body then.
What are the foot in the ear feeling here uselessness Envy
hatred even? Yes, I
think what we see here is what we would
call the infection of inadequacy the infection
of inadequacy.
What do I mean by inadequacy? I think it's something that we've all felt
at some point in our life.
I know I have.
It's in many of you are feeling it today. You're feeling low.
You're wondering if you really matter if you're able to serve the
body at all.
After all, they know the Bible better than I do or their
prayers are so full of beautiful scripture.
Where I can't sing like her.
And therefore you self declare that you
have nothing to give to the church.
But Paul appeals to the body metaphor here no matter
what the foot or the ear says. They're
inextricably part of
the body.
They cannot be separated from it.
to any believers here today who feel inadequate
understand this no matter what the adversary the
devil is telling you.
You are a part of the body.
and you matter
you matter
let's continue Paul carries out more Body Logic starting
in verse 17.
If the whole body were an eye where would be the sense of
hearing?
If the whole body were in ear where would be the sense of smell but
as it is God arranged the members
in the body each one of them as he chose.
If all were a single member where would the
body be?
As it is there are many parts yet one body.
I'm gonna be try. I'm going to try and be careful with this story.
Not really sure if there's any way around it though. So let's
do this.
My dad was an eye surgeon until a few years ago and offhomologist.
When he and my mom were in San Antonio for his residency.
He would often be called on during the middle
of the night to have to go and collect.
one or both eyes
from the scene of something if you're
following me.
Now this would be from somebody who had who
is kind enough to have had the forethought to be a donor.
And these would later be used for corneal transplants.
One night. This is the first time that my dad
was ever called out for such a run he goes and he
he collects the eyes.
in two little glass sterile jars
The office however, it was closed.
And so he couldn't stop by the office on the way home to drop
them off in Cold Storage.
the next morning
My mom wakes up.
And she's bleary-eyed and she stumbles
into the kitchen.
And she opens the door.
whoa
in the refrigerator two eyes looking straight back
at her.
wide-eyed and bushy-tailed
I'm sorry, not bushy tail just wide-eyed.
Now my question to Dad. Is this Dad. Could
you not have at least slid the eyes behind
the butter?
You know.
Now were those eyes actually looking back at
my mom?
No, because they weren't connected to the body.
And that's the point Paul is trying to make here ice can't
do anything apart from the body.
Nor can eyes be the body that would
be terrifying.
The point is this we cannot survive in isolation.
Believer you are a part of the body.
Clear up the infection of inadequacy by
understanding what God's word says about
you.
Now what is the second disease that reeks havoc on the body?
Let's pick back up in verse 21.
The eye cannot say to the hand. I have no need of
you.
Or again the head to the feet. I have no need of you on the
contrary the parts of the body that seem to be weaker are
indispensable.
And on those parts of the body that we think less honorable. We
bestow the greater honor.
And our unpresentable parts are treated with greater modesty.
Which are more presentable parts do not require.
But God has so composed the body giving greater
honor to the part that lacked it.
What does Paul saying here?
The eye that some people might see is the Superior
part is thinking less of the hand.
And the head is thinking less of the feet and they
both are in conceit in arrogance in
oozing Pride.
Saying oh you aren't important.
I don't need you.
What we see here is the contagion of conceit.
the contagion of conceit
and in face of this conceit Paul says
that those weaker parts are actually
indispensable meaning 100% absolutely
necessary
in those parts considered less honorable or actually
more honorable.
They're given greater honor and those parts considered unpresentable
those body parts that we would
consider private.
Are actually given higher care.
These are the most necessary body parts and they are given
highest status.
This is the Divine reversal.
Understand this those of you here who are
conceited believers.
Those of you who galloped in here this morning on your
high horse.
The gospel economy doesn't work like the world's economy.
What Paul is saying here is that you might think that you
are the engine, but you are at best to paint.
Which also is necessary?
Listen anytime we compare ourselves with
someone else. We're comparing with the wrong standard.
Compare yourself to Christ and you will be rightly humbled.
Understand also that your faith has come to
you on the backs of thousands of people most of whom
you'll never know who they were.
And ultimately your faith is owing to nothing that
you've done.
Nothing, it's Grace.
therefore kill the contagion of
conceit kill it
by understanding what God's word says about
you.
With all this versus 15 to 20 Paul intentionally
draws and absurd picture of the
body.
The foot and the ear feel inadequate and the
eye in the head are conceded. It's absurd to
imagine the body working that way, isn't it?
So should it be absurd for Christ's bloodbought Church
to be destroyed by the divisive
diseases of conceit and inadequacy. It's
absurd.
As we've been reading you may have noticed that I've skated quickly
over a couple verses and it's these verses that
form the most potent cure.
To our divisive diseases here.
So this is our third point we serve because we're
designed we serve because
we're designed praise God.
Let's read Verse 18 Again. The context here
is the is the body part that feels inadequate.
But as it is God arranged.
or put in place or laid
each of the body parts every one of them as he chose.
And then now in verse 24 where the context
is the body part that is conceded.
It says this but God has so composed
the body giving greater honor to the part that lacked it.
Do you see the Common Thread here Church?
In verse 18 to the believer who feels inadequate he's saying understand that
God has arranged you.
in the body
and arrange really is too weak a translation of
the Greek here, but understand this he has
knitted you together.
Psalm 139 he has given
you gifts First Corinthians 12 verse 11,
and he is specifically and meticulously
arranged You Verse 18
in the body to play a needed role.
What's more Paul not once not twice,
but three times emphasizes
God's hand in you and
in the church.
See the emphasis here. God arranged the
body parts every single one
of them including you.
as he chose
and in verse 24, this is beautiful. It speaks to me says God has
so composed the body composed.
This shows God to be the master composer a million
times greater than Beethoven and he
is mixing and blending just so to create
his Masterpiece Symphony the
church.
God is Sovereign and he is good.
God is Sovereign and he is good and view of
God's Sovereign goodness then.
Be content.
And trust the Lord and how he's gifted you.
Be content and trust the Lord how he
is gifted you.
to be anything else
is to be discontent and to
distrust the creator of the universe.
It's not a place you want to be.
We serve him because we are designed.
So far we've seen how we serve because
we're United.
Because we're different.
And because we are designed and this is a good place for us to push pause
for second here.
And to look at what does it look like to serve practically one
of our values is this idea of reimagine generosity
reimagine generosity?
Now when we think of generosity we tend to think about money.
But that's not all it is.
Instead we respond in faith by investing
not just our
money.
But our time skill effort and resources
to accomplish God's purposes.
So you might be thinking.
Then I want to serve generously how and where can
I serve?
Well, I'm glad you asked because hopefully you picked up
as he came in here this morning. We have this handy flyer. And here's
how you can serve with your body. That's the
next Point serve with your body.
one of the biggest misconceptions of a larger Church
Is that it doesn't need anything that the
opposite is true. And this list is just really
a fraction of the serving opportunities that
we have here at Henderson Hills.
Can you greet people? Well, we have we need eight greeters. For
instance. Can you drive we can
we need drivers for our Afghan Ministry?
Be a buddy in our special needs Ministry on
Sundays and Wednesdays VBS.
And one of my one of my favorites here is can you
can you slap the bass?
Then Sling It slinging a bass guitar around your neck and slap the
base.
Okay.
Or can you disciple Jesus commands
it so if you're a Believer your answer should be yes.
We have more people needing discipling then
are doing it.
Especially men and women disciplining our students.
Pour into our students we would love that.
The list is long. So just circle what
you feel led toward or what interests you and then
drop it off at the information kiosk and
somebody will reach out to you. It's easy. It's easy.
Serve with your body.
Now anytime that you want to serve I get it sometime there are
mental hurdles to get over.
But don't overthink it.
My boys have taken up tennis. And so therefore
I have
tennis is a lot like other sports in the sense of just has
to go.
Just right for that little tennis ball to go just where
you want it to go.
There are a thousand body positions and
muscular responses in tennis to keep
track of in the second that you start to analyze just
one of them can really mess with your mind.
You get nervous and you can't focus and sometimes
in sports. This mental paralysis is
called The Yips.
The Yips
now I want to be sensitive here.
that's often wrapped up in things that
are
larger issues that need to be cared for
But in tennis when The Yips come on you try to
serve but you can't.
double fault double fault double
fault
A double fault is where you make a mistake on both serves and
you you miss the point.
So what's the answer don't overthink your serve don't
overthink your serve.
Some of us in the church have serving yips.
Because it's easy to overthink it. Oh and am I
called to this is something that I can maintain for
years.
I kind of like this do I love this?
And then we get so paralyzed. We can't even take a swing.
Or we do take a swing and we we swing and miss
and it's it's a big swing and Miss but but understand
this.
That you that you tried shows
that you are engaged.
praise God for the misses
anyone here who has found their serve is standing on
a mountain of Mrs.
Practically just try one of these for two weeks see if
it fits.
If it doesn't try something else, right?
or
serve together as a CG.
Or recruit just one other person to serve
alongside you.
It's so much easier to go into something when you have somebody to be there with
you. It's a lot of fun.
So we want to encourage you here don't overthink your
serve.
You'll do great. You'll do great. I know
it.
Okay.
We would love your help.
And we'd much rather say whoa than giddy up.
Let's jump back into the text for our final truth 0.4 we
serve because we're harmonic we
serve because we're harmonic.
Now let's read that in the text starting again in verse 24
B.
But God is so composed the body giving greater honor
to the part that lacked it that there may be no division
in the body, but that the members may have the same care for
one another.
If one member suffers all suffer together if
one member is honored all Rejoice together.
Now you are the body of Christ and individually members
of it. Paul here is
painting a beautifully Rich picture of the church operating in
unity in diversity and now Harmony
in harmony because we are in sync. We're in
this together.
We suffer together. We Rejoice together co-suffering co-rejoicing.
Romans, 12:15 says something similar Rejoice with those
who rejoice and weep with those who weep.
Let that be a warning light indicator to
you when you have veered off into the
ditch of disharmony.
Be honest with yourself. Are you able to Rejoice whenever
they make the team?
Whenever they get the promotion whenever they get married.
Or whenever they get recognized and some big way.
In the same way. Do you feel their pain?
When they're weeping over the loss of their job.
Over their failing grade, their marriage
is struggling.
Or they were caught doing something.
How it should be instead to bring it back to our
text. Is this your foot is happy for
your hand.
To get to hold the new baby.
or you're I
your ear is happy that your eye gets to see.
Your bride coming down the aisle.
That is harmony.
So we see in this passage today we serve because we're United
we're different we're designed and we
are harmonic.
Let's bring this home church. Let your serving
be motivated by gospel Harmony.
That's the last point of the day let your serving be
motivated by gospel Harmony.
Do you see that here in the text that Christ is
in such harmony with you and the
church that he calls himself the head and
you his body we see that same Harmony in
Acts 9.
When Jesus confronts Saul on the road to
Damascus.
Saul as you know is the infamous and
he's the murderous persecutor of the church
Nobody pummels the church more than Saul.
And yet, it's Jesus who feels that pain?
Jesus says to Saul saw why are you
persecuting me?
Not why are you persecuting my church?
Do you see how much he loves you Church?
Do you see how much he loves you you matter?
How do we do how do we respond to this then? Well, we we serve the
Lord with gladness.
And you don't serve him as though he needed anything
acts 17 says let's not
belittle the Creator God of the
universe by thinking that he needs us or
his purposes will somehow be thwarted.
Isaiah 46 says but we serve
him with joy because of who he is because
what he's done through Christ.
amen
And let's be United Church. Let's be United.
It's been said in a similar way.
But may we not be like the Corinthian Church?
Where we have the gospel?
But we fight over the smallest stuff.
While others don't have the gospel and need it
Do you see that?
Let's be United. Let's be United unbeliever. Do
you know that this same Saul who we know better as
Paul?
This murder this persecutor of the church is the same
Paul who wrote first Corinthians that
we read today.
Paul was knocked off his figurative high horse.
And he had an encounter with Jesus. We pray
that you have an encounter with Jesus, too.
This kind of massive reversal that we've seen in today's text
where the low or brought high and high
I brought low. It's like nothing else in the
world and it's a picture of the Gospel.
Like Lindsey red at in Philippians 2 Jesus himself
was brought low and then he was highly exalted.
That images what we see here Paul shows
the power of the Gospel to bring
people who were low.
Hopelessly lost in isolated into
His Marvelous Light.
Where they are lifted high, they are
forever found and they are in the body of Christ.
And that can happen with you.
God is asking you today to trust in Jesus his
death means forgiveness for every one
of your sins. No matter what you've done.
If you turn away from your sins, and you
trust in Jesus as the Lord
of your life.
Become a part of this.
Become a part of the body of Christ.
If this is stirring something in you.
Please talk to one of us appeared down front after the
service. We'd love to talk with you about that.
The truth is this church.
To love him is to serve.
and unity with Christ
in unity with each other
drives why we serve